[Music]
so uh William thank you for coming gay
William I I'm sorry gay William thank
you for coming to my office today I who
did this office it's fabulous it's
minimalist it's masculine I like it
thank you so much you know you pick up a
chachki here yeah um why am I here well
the reason I brought you here is because
we've received several complaints from
staffers that you've been heavily
disparaging Puerto Ricans and Puerto
Rico and I think that this is out of
character for you it's very
self-deprecating self-deprecating hold
on a second I'm not Puerto Rican but um
you know on the show uh Steven says all
the time you keep my Steven's name out
of your damn mouth uh will G okay thank
you for sitting back down and I'm sorry
um I think we got off on the wrong foot
there so you're telling me that you're
not from Puerto Rico do I look stupid
and ugly no no no not at all I just
you're you're not from the island of
Puerto Rico then I I just want to make
sure call me Puerto Rican one more time
Samuel and I swear to
God so you're you're not from uh that
Island you're from a correct I'm Cuban
I'm not a murderer and I'm not Ricky
Martin okay um well the point I made
still stands you you can't just
disparage an entire island of people
who've made a very important contrib
name one um Jennifer Lopez Pig you
mentioned Ricky Martin sucker oh okay um
Shakira Puerto Rico wishes five or six
million people I'm sure there's someone
else who's important five or six million
stupid people okay well are you Jewish
yes yes I am Sam Sammy Samuel you
wouldn't rate Mel Brook over the Cole
for a joke would you oh absolutely not
he's a National Treasure mhm so those
comments you said earlier were all made
just then right serious is a heart
attack Puerto Ricans are the worst but
let me be the first to say your suit is
fabulous your taer needs a raise all
right who's the snitching Puerto Rican
out here in that
[Music]
suit remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder withcer
docomo club for $89 annually join the
fight at Lou withth cr.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today
[Music]
glad to be with you uh okay speakers off
good uh sorry about Sam from HR uh we
actually will have uh gay William later
on the show of course they resident uh
Cuban gay conservative to the right of
AA the Hun so prepare your questions uh
that'll be later on mug Club lot to get
to today let's hit the Run down some uh
not some new information but
confirmation uh former vice
president's emails 82,000 emails now
have been uh uncovered from former Vice
President Joe Biden take a
guess take a guess what's in there we'll
go through that yeah it confirms
everything we talked about this
yesterday but we wanted to take some
time to go through the information a
little bit more uh we also have an
exclusive today a mug Club undercover um
with the illegal migrant Title Wave
that's been taking place across the
country what's very surprising is you
might think look put in your your mind's
eye what do you think of when you think
of illegal immigrants the latest
Caravans that's not
it and we had someone on the ground who
by the way got in trouble with the
authorities for filming uh even though
he had the right to so uh just want you
to stay tuned for that and we'll
probably at some point have to hit the
YouTube dump button watch on Rumble and
uh throat cancer something we'll be
discussing today as well so let me ask
you this um you know what never mind let
me just introduce everybody first when
you hear this you know him you know who
it is he's going to be at Bricktown
Comedy Club November 5th Oklahoma City
Oklahoma Mr Josh firin how are you good
morning I'm good I'm good you I'm
excited for the throat cancer segment
yes yes it's not really a
segment um well I mean it never is long
enough
no uh and Gerald is at maral Lago right
now and I believe we'll be doing the
debate stream next week too so we might
have some exclusive interviews on there
so that is why Josh is in kind of second
here and then in third chair when you
hear this oh yeah it's pops Crowder how
are you sir I'm great it's more of a
deep dive Josh than a segment
yeah we're going to get wet folks that's
what she said sorry hey we miss you
Gerald it's the big idea never did I
think that my father would come on the
show and make it
worse to people listening on audio in
four minutes you're going to
retroactively go oh God uh
all right so uh I guess I have a
question for you before I run this
clip H why do you think that most
husbands are upset if let's say their
wives create an only fans there's a
problem right now uh throughout the
country there's an
epidemic I guess I should say h not
really it's just happening guys are
getting upset and how would you react I
guess if you were a husband and wife is
that something that you would consider I
guess if you needed to pay the bills
because this has been going viral but
there's a few Dynamics at play here uh
former NBA player Joe Smith he uh found
out and then his wife as a good wife
does videotaped his reaction or film
sorry I hate it's not videotape it's
some iPhone camera we used to say
videotaped film anyways sorry throwback
she filmed her husband's reaction when
he found out that she had an only fans
and uh he reacted in a way that uh
shouldn't be
surprising I have only fans and he's mad
because he's just now finding out about
it of course I'm mad just find out about
it I'm not doing it with anybody but
myself so tell you my choice my body my
body supped to come Joe I've been
talking to you about mad things I've
been asking for solutions to not giving
me none so I created one that's no
solution not in my book but Pause by the
way the book He's referring to is a Joe
Smith's guide on how to not be a lying
so that's
to be fair he may have a bias with his
book didn't make top 10 no it did not it
was an Amazon bestseller but it wasn't
New York Times Oprah's reading list no
one know yeah Although our next segment
is one of her favorite things let's
continue he breaking me off what the
come on with that it don't matter what
they breaking you off it's the
disrespect that comes with it what
disrespect you couldn't come and talk to
me about it okay well we're talking
about it now okay live streaming yeah
live streaming an when you're
caught this is not I I have an apple
scin stuck in the front of my teeth I'm
sorry damn it with the apples we're
problem in this office with apples all
right here's the problem it used to be
and and you guys can comment below and I
I understand now this woman was an adult
video star before he married her okay so
guys you need to make better decisions
you can't be you can't be surprised as
though it's unexpected if you married
someone who was an adult film star okay
now for the rest of the guys though who
do run into these situations and we've
run these clips before for where all of
a sudden the wife starts an only fans or
a girlfriend it used to be if you were
one of those guys and you you decided
that you were going to pick up marry a
stripper or a hooker okay you kind of
accepted it you're like okay or you were
a guy who wanted a nice woman who was
not those things not you can't be a nice
woman but you wanted a non- stripper
let's put it that way I don't want a sex
shame you wanted a non- hooker H as as
someone you know when you're talking
about the betroth okay that's fair but
now it's okay you marry a nice lady yeah
no I got a nice wife and then oh and
she's a stripper now I guess that just
changed you're a hooker
you weren't now she is huh everything
that changes the entire landscape and if
a man gets upset they videotape it by
the way you know if she wasn't filming
him he would have been way mad and
rightfully so yeah rightfully so he
knows he can't go he can't say what he
wants to yeah he's famous and he's on uh
he's on live he j a pink it at her EXA
he wants it's very different what's
wrong with what is wrong and ain't
nobody want to see that just all that
stuff like yeah and you know she would
be worse too throwing crap
a vase would break against a wall at
some point in time so
unsurprisingly Joe Smith left the house
uh but this woman the perfect angel that
she
is still placing the blame on him yes
the first question is where's Jo are you
how are you guys doing where's
Joe um pretty pissed off with me so he's
been um I think he's at his sister's
house he's not talking right now so
Thanksgiving going to be off the chain
home I'm trying not to lose and a and a
roof over here we're trying to maintain
almost got kicked out of so I just
kicked in the and did what I had to do
you know and he won't do it so I had to
and I'm sorry you knew I was an adult
video star when you met me so if my
survival if I would do anything for my
own Survival then what makes you think
that would change now you should have
paid attention when your teacher taught
you the Fable of the Frog and the porn
actress oh I remember that one I was a
when you rescued me so my question
to you is who who do you think is to
blame here again there's a dynamic that
she was an adult videos okay fine got it
but the issue is a complete lack of
accountability notice how you'll hear
this a lot with people who those
FiveFinger discounts in San Francisco
it's well I had to we were going to get
kicked out survival yeah in her case
it's his fault he wasn't paying the
bills he wasn't so he's he's doing
nothing he's not contributing and the
only way the only way
to pay the bills when you're married to
a former NBA star was to uh sell
yourself naked online pornographically
there's no other option it's all I know
it's all I know how to do it's all I
know what am I supposed to get get a job
at a
library well it might not be bad you
might you might learn to shut the up I
don't know how many jobs there are at
libraries but uh there's a couple some
it's all I know well you don't know it
that good that's what would have
happened if the camera wasn't running
and every was like I cannot believe it's
his fault it's his fault and so now he
has to accept it uh accept it however
the cards May lie I mean there there's
some responsibility on him she's
ultimately wrong but like she had a she
had a link she said she had a link for
months yeah he didn't even he's not even
looking at her Instagram he's and he was
talking to some other girl it's they're
both yeah it seems like they may maybe
they deserve each other but left him and
took some money with her no in in
context though Marley was a porn started
begin with I mean he knew what he was
getting into here yes did he did he know
he was being filmed pops are killing it
today did did he know he's being filmed
or live streamed Tim he just I assume he
okay yeah of course he knew he saw it he
saw it he's out there yeah he and you
know it just he's like he's like what
did I just find you oh hey I do not
agree with this decision y'all
and I do not respectfully and then you
oh hey and I think that it
would be best for our family unit if you
shut the answer my objection good job
marrying Dickens and uh porn star all
right the way he reacted it's like he's
she's done this before yes yeah yeah
it's like oh you got the camera on again
there's no privacy anymore is the issue
there's no privacy like this is the
thing a marital dispute I mean we lived
through it with with Johnny Depp and
Amber herd and then everyone else found
out oh with context what they knew was
wrong and uh it's an entire guy a big
big star at some point was he a a good
player I don't know I was wearing a
Golden State Warrior shirt so I got to
assume he was like a bench player on a
championship team yeah I don't know we
made the show but doesn't mean he's you
know still wealthy yeah but he's
thrilled with uh next this next study so
uh and again we always say this is a
PG-13 show and this isn't for children
but this is true uh a new study uh shows
that uh Kel Lingus is now the leading
cause of throat cancer or doctors are
discussing this according to some new
research the higher incidents of
Americans engaging in oral sex
specifically kind Lingus carries a
greater risk of oral HPV contraction and
now statistically leads to to a higher
probability risk of developing oral
cancer than smoking tobacco or hard
alcohol use this comes from a new study
that's now being referred to as the God
hates lesbians but loves black guys
research well it's a sliver respect to
black guys for standing their
ground they' held true that's a that's a
manifest destiny that's Survival the
fittest uh by the way if at any point
today if it hasn't been hit
yet you see this the YouTube dump button
yeah yeah that means head on over to uh
that means head on over to rumble uh and
of course uh you know we'll continue on
mug clip today Gay William and your
chats and we have some we have some
exclusive footage today from the the
latest migrant Caravan Fiasco what's
happening in New York City and you never
know you never know with YouTube they
might hit you with your strike they
might tell you to remove it even though
it's well within the parameters of the
law so uh you may see that button quite
a bit today okay can we send that that
the Kinga story can I get a link to that
to send my
wife how about new like see that like
you like Joe Smith video she be like
well you're
safe you should use the other cameras
more pixels I've been robbed of all my
mom jokes today
terrible all right so uh former Vice
President Biden you know he's corrupt
right you know that and you know that
we've talked about the Hunter Biden
story and that's been suppressed okay
but this is another example of I guess
you should say corroborating research uh
that the media has been fundamentally
uninterested in covering at all now this
isn't just about you know the hilarity
that his son wears an ascot and smokes
parmeson cheese this is about the fact
that the man sitting in the Oval Office
napping in the Oval Office uh has used
his office used his vice presidential
office back then for political gain in a
way that is undoubtedly corrupt and
illegal you would think the media would
be interested in this remember Watergate
remember Aaron Brockovich it was about
tap water that nothing media silence so
first let's uh set this up all
references available L withth credit.com
this is a new lawsuit by the southern
Legal Foundation it's uh revealed that
Joe Biden sent 82,000 emails using
pseudonyms during his tenure as vice
president and as far as we have seen and
I'll actually ask you to help out here
because we've looked and we haven't been
able to find anything thus far only Fox
business has broadcasted it's a stunning
amount 82,000 emails they've produced 14
so they have
81,9 186 more to go but this is how many
instances Joe Biden used a fake name to
conduct government business on his
government email so here we have a
president that used a fake name a
pseudonym in a government email at least
82,000 times now for for context
Hillary's private server it only had
33,000 emails so we're talking about
over 880,000 emails uh largely with
pseudonyms and and by the way some of
the pseudonyms have raised concerns
themselves regarding him leading a
double life it turns out he took a side
gig as Charles E
cheese and uh he also worked temporarily
as a good humor Delivery
Man and honestly most most
disappointing he moonlit as a Nigerian
prince asking for money and I I'm more
upset that's true though come on I'm
more upset with myself for sending money
oh well Western Union didn't have my
back Stephen you're too generous man
I've telling you why do you dress up
it's an email
okay he's in car he got it from Nancy
bosi very convincing yes okay so here's
the thing a lot of the content is
unknown that's part of the reason why we
didn't want to just cover it yesterday
we wanted to a see if we could get some
more information on this content and B
see how the media would cover it
so um here's what we do know as far as
what is included in these emails um
there's there's emails uh there there
there are emails that coincide I should
say that at least the claim right now
2014 to 2019 you know Hunter served on
the board of brisma okay that seems to
be included in these email some
information regarding that 2015 I
remember the vpa John Flynn uh included
Hunter on emails following Joe former
Vice President Joe Biden's threats to
withhold aid from Ukraine again burisma
Ukraine Right company Hunter serves on
that board for people who don't remember
and then you had Joe Biden threatened to
withhold Aid at this same period of time
and I went over I I guess the 12th 13th
time to keeve and uh and I was going
supposed to announce that there was
another billion dollar loan guarantee
and I had gotten a commitment from
poreno and from uh yatsenuk that they
would take action against the state
prosecutor and they did didn't so they
said they had they walking out at the
Press conf said no I said I'm not going
to we're not going to give you the
billion dollars they said you have no
Authority you're not the president the
president said I said call
him I said I'm telling you you're not
getting the billion dollars right now
remember this is one of those things
this is the uh the prosecutor he's
referring to is is uh Victor shoken
right who was dismissed eventually so
this all ties into to Hunter Biden
investigations going on 2016 they're at
at least 10 emails that cced Hunter
Biden this comes from the New York Post
it says at least 10 misses were sent
between May 18th and June 15th 2016 and
cced firston Hunter Biden with one on
May 26th notifying Hunter of a scheduled
phone call the next day between the vice
president and uh Ukrainian president uh
Petro proen penko I may not pronounce
that properly okay and the National
Archives said that it will quote produce
non-exempt files on a monthly rolling
basis uh going for forward and rumor has
it that over 2,000 them were Obama
asking to be lit out of the White House
laundry room so we don't
know
now ni thanks Nick
um so you would think hey corruption
right this should be like catnip for the
media corruption International it's
basically you know if James Bond was a
geriatric I'd like to see that movie and
here is the kind of out rage that you
see from the media yesterday when this
happened and uh through today this
evening covering the story as you would
imagine non-stop we turn now to an ABC
News exclusive involving former
president Trump and nuclear secrets
closing arguments are expected to take
place today in the trial of FTX founder
Sam bankman freed the United States
Congress began this week with the
speaker of the house and both of its
Chambers in session Britain's King
Charles and queen Camila are in Kenya
for a state visit sorry I screwed up I
showed you the opposite of that now what
was an important story yeah well
yesterday CNN MSNBC ABC CBS NBC cover
the
story guess how you know what comment
below pause if you're listening to audio
guess zero times
none not
one now facts don't exist in a vacuum
let's contrast that provide some context
with the treatment of President Donald
Trump's documents we're learning today
that Trump's lawyer has receipts and
that special councel Jack Smith lawyers
have receipts the case involves Trump's
handling of classified documents after
he left office for months Mr Trump
refused to return the documents despite
multiple requests that led to a raid of
his Mara Lago estate back in August
tonight an historic shakeup in the race
for the White
House did they do that or did we do
that did they do that shake I hope we
did that we we did not do that shake
Jacob like let me do it like an ET
sketch news was that Gerald in the
background someone in the office like
let's do shake and bake Lyall you're
fired but I like the eter sketch thing
he's at marago isn't he is he in that
storage room could where Waldo I have no
idea he's wearing his tuck all right
let's continue I just was bothered by
legitimate news doing Shake screen
effect that was an intern front runner
former president Trump facing Federal
criminal charges begin tonight with
breaking news news we have obtained what
is expected to be a central piece of the
government's case against Donald Trump
the actual audio recording recording of
the former president talking as if he's
showing a highly classified document on
us War plans against
Iran and and by the way yesterday
morning CNN with again the 82,000 new
emails under
pseudonyms former Vice President Joe
Biden yesterday morning CNN was still
covering the document now I need to I
tell tell you this because you'd watch
it and think oh that's from months ago
no yesterday morning when the story
broke CNN was instead covering this was
a crucial Hearing in the marago
classified documents case lawyers for
former president Trump expected to
formally make another attempt to try to
delay this until after the election now
team Trump has repeatedly complained to
the judge that they haven't had proper
access to classified evidence in the
case as they prepare for the
trial so 82 thou just to be clear 82,000
emails under pseudonyms we did our our
search not just on air uh we search
these
websites nothing here's proof CNN MSNBC
ABC CBS
NBC and I'm going to ask you please
comment you are this is crowdsourcing
this is crowdsourcing information run
your own searches for the Biden email
stories on this from yesterday on these
mainstream Outlets let me know what you
find comment below and hit like if you'd
rather watch paint dry than than than
CNN at this point you can hit that like
button it helps with the algorithm but
imagine that nothing and when people try
and say man the corporate media and they
try and make it sound like it's
right-wing because of Corporations again
CNN MSNBC ABC CBS NBC nothing nothing
well they all received an email from
Charles E cheese yes they did telling
him to kindly not run the story yes it
was an Ecard that you open up You Say
It's Your
Birthday me it's not news like nothing
that what they do is news no nothing is
news anymore and then then they try to
Gaslight you and say oh what happened to
legitimate news in this country well
aren't you're the same people who didn't
cover this level of corruption with the
sitting vice president and uh at the
same time also said that Joe Rogan was
taking a horse medication yeah and then
demand that big Tech three companies
fact check and determine misinformation
based on well of course the White House
as well our federal government and you
MSNBC CNN CBS ABC NBC
nothing and then they tell you I can you
believe that Donald Trump said that the
media is the enemy yeah and this isn't
just to conservatives don't does it not
matter at this point this this directly
affects National Security this actually
affects your day-to-day life especially
when you're talking about over hundred
billion dollar committed to
Ukraine I just what does it take does it
about political parties at that point
it's about uh yourself and your country
right I want to be deceived yeah I think
we were this is the we know every single
mistake that Donald Trump has ever made
we know all about it we know every
single mistake we don't know about
82,000
emails I was surprised to learn just
there that Hunter worked or was on the
board of barisma for five years yeah wow
I thought it was a short stint you know
and they kind of slapped his and he was
off but five years and he largely worked
from home yeah he he never showed up he
was at barisma longer than he was doing
crack no he wasn't I doubt that I doubt
that CRA so I mean you know he's Pro
he's still doing a little crack every
now and then sure I mean who doesn't
yeah I know he was there another 3 years
after they fired the the prosecutor yeah
well cuz at that point he like okay I
guess I'm through the worst so hold on
second really what are they talking
about on C speaker Michael Johnson
holding his first formal news conference
and the reason for that say when it
comes back Senate that's your look right
oh that's what he looks like their their
decision they have to make on their own
but our decision is look the reason we
pulled it from the Israel fund is that's
a a pile of money $67 billion it's
sitting over there to uh refurbish uh
build up and and hire new uh IRS agents
and the rest um if you have to look at
uh the this the scope and the um
importance of our commitments right now
uh my belief is that these this dire
situation in Israel is so important okay
all right well I'm glad that he we we'll
see how that develops but I'm glad that
he's talking about building up the IRS I
mean it's it's talk about how remarkable
the media is at lying to people no one
likes the IRS yeah who I guarantee if
people knew that did you just say $87
billion that $87 billion was going to
refurbish the IR no one would be on
board with that so what happens is they
just don't really cover it they give you
a fact check in Snopes that say no there
are not going to be 80s something
thousand new IRS agents employees but
they're not all agents that's it that's
all you get M so it's not just the
stories that they lie to you about it's
what they choose not to cover that's the
most corrosive uh form of lie I would
say that happens in the media the most
consistent lie every single day it's
just what they choose absolutely not to
cover and before you say that we're
biased here yes we absolutely are I just
don't lie to you about it we provide all
the references uh and put the link in
the description I am of course I'm
biased I revile the left it's not enough
this day and age it's not enough to just
believe in the country you have to
revile what people are doing to the
country at this point you have to have
great disdain for it if we're going to
change anything that's why I don't try
and fake middle ground it but you know
hey uh speaking of corruption and what
what the media chooses not to cover we
want you to tell us about it uh you can
send your tips to lwc tips
protonmail.com this is what mug Club
supports if you guys are not members
lit.com mug Club you get two times a
show every day you get a Friday show
Alex Jones on Friday you get Nick doollo
every day Hodge twins Brian K Mr gunsen
gear uh and you support a lot of these
Endeavors that frankly if this was just
business wouldn't make sense but it
matters as far as impact on the country
so we have an undercover investigative
unit and uh if you do send something in
we'll protect our sources uh with our
lives there people here are willing to
go to jail to protect their sources so
you will be your privacy is Paramount to
us let me set this up uh as far
as this story a bit of a refresher so
another huge caran of illegal uh what do
we say they don't want to say no human
beings are illegal you know what just
illegal people they're making irregular
yeah irregular
atypical
unmonitored actually no we're going to
get to they have ankle monitors right
yeah that's what they do we pay for
ankle monitors so uh another Caravan of
illegals is making its way to our
Southern border to take advantage of the
open border policy and right now we
actually I guess have an exclusive clip
at the southern
[Applause]
[Music]
border
this wrong clip sorry let's grab the the
the newest clip mostly peaceful of the
migrant
Caravan a caravan with an estimated
5,000 migrants are heading north towards
the US the movement on the heels of a
record-breaking year for migrant
encounters along the Southwest border in
recent months city leaders experiencing
a spike in migrant Crossings sought
support from the federal government all
right so before I give you refresher on
what has been happening in our country
with uh illegal immigrants and how it's
a crisis um well you know what this is M
Club
Undercover
[Music]
okay so remedial how bad has the Border
policy been okay and we'll give you uh
some contrast to again because facts
don't exist in just a vacuum uh
comparing this with Donald Trump's
presidency where I also wonder at what
point do we say okay all right it's
gotten worse the economy International
turmoil uh certainly our our our policy
at the border so since
January 2021 we've had approximately 7
million encounters at the southern
border now that's a record jeez 2023
alone there have been 2.48 million
encounters at the southern border again
a
record now let's just go to a month
September 2023
269,000 35 encounters at the southern
border again a record this is four times
four times the monthly arrivals compared
to under President Trump's watch under
President Trump's watch the average
monthly encounters around 41,000 now
were somewhere around 179
180,000 jez to give you some scale
amazing Biden has imported more illegals
than the population of 35 States 35
States
wow and here's what I was asking before
in your minds ey when you think illegal
immigrants and you rightfully think this
because the left has labeled you as
racist you probably think of that's not
it you think of Mexican immigrants
crossing the border so with these
numbers 22,000 of them from January SE
uh January to September 2023
Chinese January to September Venezuela
160,000 Venezuelans jeez wow 51,000
people from the Middle East that's
dangerous and these numbers by the way
don't include goway and I'm pretty sure
that there are a lot of those because
they really don't want these numbers
getting out and now you have the FBI
warning of terrorists coming through the
Border I thought it was mostly families
yes it was mostly we'll get to that
right yeah mostly children terrorists
can be families too they can yeah so
they they can be families especially if
they're middle-aged military male uh and
single Hitler loved his kids Hitler bad
yeah Hitler bad just just so everyone
knows Hitler bad anytime we reference
Hitler Hitler Hitler very
bad so here's Chris Ray and have to say
FBI director because you wouldn't
believe it unless I said so but you know
this if you looked at him like no way
yeah he warned Americans about uh Hamas
inspired terrorism just this week the
reality is that the terrorism threat has
been elevated throughout 2023 but the
ongoing war in the Middle East has
raised the threat of an attack against
Americans in the United States to a
whole another level you know you just
wish that you could actually get these
people in like a deposition
hold on a second you said that there was
no crisis at the southern border you
said that it was not an issue as it
relates to National Security and now
when politically expedient you say well
there could be Hamas likee terrorists
well that's what we've been saying no no
no you were just racist well no hold on
a second people have the right they have
the right to be concerned about illegal
Mexican immigrants coming to this
country they have the right to be
concerned about MS-13 they have the
right to be upset about crime at the
southern border they also have the right
to be concerned and I would say
rightfully so regarding terrorists going
through the Border regarding people
coming from any country who don't
respect or appreciate the Western civil
the American way of life they absolutely
you labeled them as racist it's not
racist only as it relates to National
Security but it always relates to
National Security so just to give you
more context here and this is where we
go to um what is exclusive people here
hard at work mug Club undercover a lot
of these people are coming from from
African countries like like Sagal and
guinea and then also the Middle East
China we have a montage here I believe
yeah this is from mug Club undercover MH
uh and it's really concerning and then
we have a lot more and even more
concerning throughout this segment
you'll see the authorities police
officers people who are supposed to look
out for
you instead they're running interference
for them so here you go yo where you
from cool welcome you guys stand here
the r yes yeah what'd you get here
uh days yeah how'd you get here on you
got
here from GID GID oh W from yeah
people how did it start you
start start by beginning I start by by
your
by how long is that trip what how long
week 2 weeks 3 weeks we 3 weeks you just
got here toight no just are of people
from Africa coming for sure yeah I saw a
bunch people in Sagle
the last bus I saw
yeah 15 days 15 days right yeah yeah I
know where that is so so I we were
talking before so you landed in Mexico
and then how did you get to this cold
place how why how did you get
here Day Day M yeah California
California California wow
so so these people are part of the these
Caravans right now going to New York
City now imagine let's say southern
Texas where they basically get to fly
direct they're not going to New York
City they're just hopping over the
border and there's no real way to track
it so this is going to be the least
severe this is going to be the mildest
uh group of migrants that you can see as
far as as as far as where they're coming
from and giving you a sample size so we
have illegal uh migrants who are uh now
going by the bus load arriving and
occupying hotels in New York City and I
mean occupying like uh the
[Music]
Roosevelt
all right and the people who are
supposed to be looking out for you and
this is why I'm also not one of those
just back the blue period right because
you have good police and you have bad
police and unfortunately in cities where
there's corruption you end up with uh
those in charge those with authority who
rather than looking out for you are
taking part in the systematic uh abusing
of you they were not happy the
authorities in New York with our
undercover units uh filming these
breaking the not tou one canot take
pictures we can you can stand there weo
don't get in my way you're not going to
be on camera don't touch with the Box
not touch the box it's okay where we
stand call the police call the police if
you have a me the Poli if you're going
to get in our way I can't help it I'm
trying to film in there you're in my way
don't touch me do not touch me do not
touch me do not touch me fil me bro if
you don't get in my way it won't film
you it's that
easy just taking over now
huh and here here's something it gets
even worse have to provide some context
here um there have been basically these
gangs who use scooters which sounds
hilarious scooter
gangs scoot scoot scoot to the fight
it's the hover
Crips but it's true they've actually
been the vehicle of choice for a lot of
criminals in New York City you've
probably read some headlines um
regarding this some of them call them
mopeds scooters
mopeds why they just a scooter is an
easy getaway it's you snatch a purse or
you commit and boom you can get off and
they just they'll leave them uh
sometimes so here you have our
undercover unit uh finding a a a large
group a cache if you will of
scooters illegally parked outside the
hotel and you would think hey here's a
tip off officer ah no these illegal
scooters is your side off
the illegal scooters legally
parked police just just take the
scooters just ask them like hey are
those your SC they're illegally parked
you have but we'll get tickets you'll
get tickets for going five over you have
a crime wave in your city It is Well
document and acknowledged by the police
department that scooters are a are the
transportation vehicle of choice which
again is hilarious but
true they're there and nothing happens
the guy was nodding in the video he's
like these are illegal scooters like
yeah I don't think he was a cop I'm not
sure but there was there were other
police in New York in the winter yeah
this is your vehicle of choice now he
just he's just a guy who appreciates a
good
vehicle so that is well the cops in New
York they're busy uh they're busy
hassling people sitting down at the
train station yes yes they're busy
hassling those people don't Vape in
front of them oh they hate it oh yeah
yeah I thought you meant like those lime
scooters where the illegals have to tap
their government issued credit card to
buy some time way they go oh yeah that
though that's a that's what you call
double dipping using an EBT card for a
lime scooter and knocking over a liquor
store you know what game respects game
right I paid for your felony don't the
player so it's one of those new tap
cards okay you're
off pay his bail with that thing that's
right oh there's no bail in New York
there's no there's no bail you need a
pil you don't need unless you're unless
you're a white guy who you know
committed a misdemeanor so uh here's the
thing this is this is a a consistent
pattern outside of the United States
really the largest Immigration Court in
the United States uh this Federal Plaza
in New York City the
lines for these illegal M they were
extraordinarily long so I think we even
had to right we sped this up with a time
lap because I don't want to waste your
time all the references are Avail and by
the way we'll release these clips in
their full context uh on on Twitter on X
those places so you can follow me there
but uh we have to shorten this uh for
the sake of a
program okay that that looks sped up
yeah the line wasn't as long as as
you're making exactly that's what
they'll say yeah this was edited out of
context fine
well they just opened a new uh bagel
shop yes yes waiting for their uh wait
for their bagel and shmear it's free
coffee
day right and here's something that may
not make sense to you and it shouldn't
so some of these migrants were sent to
New York City from uh California and
they wear what at first glance you're
going hold on a second are those ankle
monitors uh spoiler alert yes but I'll
explain why after California gave you
those she PS mod
us that's
crazy wow yeah hey I'm glad they didn't
take it off yes right and the one of the
officers they actually confronted one of
our cameramen there when he found out uh
that the migrants had ankle monitors um
well they were Usher they were ushered
right in here you go I'm have you guys
oh we're just asking them about the SE
before yeah yeah let's go yeah wait what
can
yes is it a California thing all come
come on let's go
yeah just get in the line over
there can you help do you know why they
do the
GPS that's crazy uh ankle monitors like
why do they have that on their ankles I
have no idea it's up to ice ice
interesting so I guess ice in
California so if uh people are asking
questions as to why these ankle matters
let me explain it to you it's part of a
program called firm FM the family
expedited removal management uh plan and
it was created back in May I think uh
May of 2023 specifically for families
right with children to expedite
processing whether they're admitted or
whether they end up being sent back um
that's what they claim this was
allegedly for expedited removal however
uh through May and August I believe are
the numbers that we have uh yeah
bringing up CBS yeah May through August
only 80 out of 2800 people were
deported now here's the thing this is
designed for
families there are no children in this
video none at all people who are wearing
these ankle bracelets now you might say
okay maybe they're not around at that
point in time I didn't see wedding rings
I know cultural differences
but firm also comes with some
restrictions so one of them is not being
outside 11:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m. right
comes with like a curfew
uh people there were in line at 2:
a.m. just to be clear and about one year
ago uh single adults with ankle monitors
were part of what was called an
alternative to detention program which
means yeah instead of uh repercussions
for your crimes write this way so that
was something that we also to deal with
so none of this makes a lot of sense
it's muddled and the authorities are
running interference you see there you
have the National Guard and then you
have police officers who at best have no
idea what's going on and at worst are
aiding and abetting
what Christopher Ray just said was
basically a national security risk so
never again be
allowed never again sorry never again
allow them to to to force you to feel
guilty for wanting people to sign the
guest book on the way into this country
you have no idea you have no idea who's
coming in and here's the thing let's say
you do have an idea as to who's coming
in then you have bumbling government
bureaucracy who is incapable of
enforcing their own laws and this is in
New York City think about that what do
you think's happening in El Paso what do
you think ha what do you think is
happening on our Southern
border so my my question is to you is
this surprising at
all to you that it's not just people
coming in from Mexico but people from
across the world using Mexico as an
entry point and do you think that we are
due for I know when we asked this before
people said unlikely do you think that
there's going to be a terrorist attack
or that it's possible here on uh on
American
soil considering the record number 200
is it 280,000
269,000 just in the month of September
this last month or two months ago yeah
and then they want to pass gun
legislation right yeah so uh we really
do appreciate those uh who've been doing
this work for us and again uh send us
your tips especially if you work at a
government agency we've been working
with some on some other stories uh send
your tips to lwc tips at
protonmail.com you are the eyes and ears
everywhere and that's what Andrew
Breitbart said when he talked about he
wanted to watch journalism as it was
referred to he was saying traditional
back then Legacy Media die he said you
have an iPhone you have a smartphone you
have a camera you have a camera wherever
you go you are now the media you are now
journalism and we want to make sure that
we do right by you this has been uh mug
Club
[Music]
Undercover
all right we I want we always have to
make sure we do justice to those clips
so I know our mics are off but any any
of that surprise you I'm surprised that
our people pointed out the monitors to
them then the cop comes up and gives
them a FastPass right away when he
realizes they're there but he doesn't
even know what it means yeah or is that
a different cop look like same it seems
like none of them really know what's
happening are they all kind of chubby
Puerto Ricans or just just that one hey
well you know the the Sharks realize
that that crime doesn't pay yeah decided
to be be part of the blue I don't know
how we we dial this back this is so
scary so ugly yeah yeah the the biggest
problem is they call us racist oh you're
racist cuz you don't want uh Mexicans
coming across the border you want brown
people coming across the border that's
not it at all I don't want people don't
know coming across the border I would be
devastated if somebody come came across
the border bombed up a mall shot up a
mall or something in El Paso 90% Mexican
ameran and Mexicans with visas yeah were
hurt or killed that would be devastating
of course yeah it's not about race
that's that's like that argument is
crazy man oh yeah and the crazy thing
too is in these Sanctuary cities we did
a change my mind you know you know who
that negatively affects it affects
law-abiding citizens in a lot of those
cities because criminals use them as
sanctuaries and so we had a lady her uh
let's call her F when we were doing a
change my mind she said how she she took
me said asked her face to be blur said
how how can I report these people
because I'm in neighborhoods now we have
a lot of a lot of illegal migrants
entering in there's crime but you know I
I don't know how to report them we're in
a sanctuary City and um the truth is I
didn't fully have an answer I didn't
know the process and by the way I
certainly can't instill confidence in
her that they won't they won't we back
be back out on the street and looking to
find out who snatched was that a new
scenario you weren't aware of cuz that
was I remember watching that thinking I
didn't even think about that I didn't
think about being in that culture of the
same of the immigrants that are coming I
mean I was aware of it existing but I I
I certainly didn't know the steps that
she should take to best protect herself
sure well she still has to live in that
neighborhood that's something that you
guys don't you you often don't think
about and often it's the same it's the
same type of uh problem that we run into
the dynamic when they were talking about
defunding the police who do you think
that negatively affects the most the
law-abiding citizens in Crim ridden
areas it's the people who want to get
out of the south side of Chicago yeah
let's call it what it is largely black
but they eventually want to get out but
right now they still have to be there
they're stuck there if they're a
teenager they're stuck there and because
of you privileged white government
government bureaucrats well we're going
to we're going to defund the police that
kid is now worse off that kid just has
to he has to watch the clock and go okay
just survive until I get to the point
where I can get out of here because now
I'm in an area that's riddled with crime
and there's no one coming to help me
it's what you get with Sanctuary cities
it's what you get with defunding the
police it's what you get and it's all
under the guise of compassion right
Sanctuary cities compassion hey defund
the police compassion right there are
two look the police are racist well hold
on a second these people are just
seeking a better life the left it really
is it comes down to it's like raising a
child giving them everything they want
that's not compassionate it's the same
thing with puberty puberty blockers and
and sex change reassignments that's
you're just giving the kid what they
think they want but they don't actually
know what they want and especially by
the way if you're allowing one child to
get what they want and it harms the rest
of your family if you have three or four
other children that's not compassionate
what part of this that you are seeing
there seems to be checking all the boxes
of compassion even if they come here
illegally and they they get that ankle
bracelet removed what kind of a life do
you think that's that's going to be
we're seeing these people become less
compassionate too yeah in these cities
and it's only a matter of time before
probably when before it's too it'll be
too late but it's only a matter of time
before they go oh yeah we need to yeah
we need to do something about this right
yeah it's it's a it be we should have
yeah we should have oh should have would
have could have should have would have
could have people will say oh hold on a
second we've talked about this too and
change my Minds where they'll say
actually you know know immigrants here
are the most law-abiding group that
exists and I'm I'm sure Mission Control
can pull this up no that's not true that
would be actually concealed carry
holders uh what they do is they throw
together the list of legal immigrants
and illegal immigrants it's not the same
thing of course if someone came here
legally these generally are people who
not only are on the books and so they
can be held accountable for their
actions but they want to be a part of
the United States they went through a
legal process they're naturally likely
to be more law abiding than someone who
hasn't then don't want to lose that
paper baby yeah don't blame them but
then when you
factor you take you take into account
illegal migrants now this is a very hard
number to uh to to come up with because
we don't know how many illegal
immigrants there are right that's the
math that's the math trickery that they
pull they are many times more likely
some Studies have them four times more
likely some Studies have them up to 13
times more likely to commit violent
crimes but there is no study when
accounting for illegal immigrants that
shows anything than several multiple
several multiples of a higher rate of
violent crime likelihood well
okay who does that affect and this is
why you're seeing a reshaping of the map
in politics this is why people are
surprised that oh hold on a second a lot
of Voters don't feel like like the
Democrat Party is representing us well
yeah because even before you get to the
fact that you've put them at risk their
physical safety a lot of them are losing
jobs to people who are coming from
countries who will work for 16 cents a
day in a sweat shop they don't want to
they don't want to lose that first you
call them racist and they also don't
want to see their nephews head on a
turtle bigots you know as scary as those
numbers are you know they're
incentivized to suppress them right
they're going to be way big and Goda
ways that number is way bigger yeah of
course it is I didn't even know we had a
term got oh got away what do we call him
a got away in Israel to be honest what I
thought it was a town in Israel yes yes
could be it could be at least yeah Big
Town you never forget the MS13 who got
away that was my love what could have
been that was look man our love was true
holes it was
P would a rose by any of their names SM
sweet I don't think so
bro you should have seen her in the low
rider when I hit the switches bop bop
you know what I'm saying that's right
you know and then I told her like what's
it her name
holes she said what I said the
Shakespeare dog
[Laughter]
by the way undo your bottom buttons only
the top button what are you thinking bro
gross that's a look like little
fly what are you going hunting you're
like a B pro you're buttoning all your
buttons bro just a top
button all right speaking of compassion
uh we are going to have a man here for
mug Club chat has none gay
William
and uh this is as good a time as any to
let you know if you're watching on
Rumble click that button where you get
to chat with uh with all of us it's chat
Thursday but certainly gay William if
you're watching on YouTube there's
nothing I can do for you hit the like
button helps with the algorithm gay
William how are you sir oh good morning
I'm good how are you you were just doing
the the drag queen of England voice
again accidentally that was an ugly drag
queen I know Joe Lewis didn't want to go
anywhere near you no he was scared he
would his tail stopped wagging he just
looked at
me God his tail never stops never stops
wagging that was honestly a Marvel uh
all right so we're going to take some
chat you guys often have a lot of
questions for uh gay William and of
course Josh thank you for your service
you're going to be at Bricktown Comedy
Club yes in Oklahoma City this Sunday
this Sunday Oklahoma City Bricktown
Comedy Club
things what go see homo things it'll be
good yeah we're going be doing some homo
things it'll be great see um and uh
Gerald is going to be back I think next
week we will be doing a stream of the
debate I believe Wednesday but we we may
have some exclusive uh may be someone
special but I I I don't I don't know
yet the lawyers always tell me you can't
say things until you confirm all the
things and so this is hard let's just go
to chat on mug Club where I feel like
I'm judged less thank you Rumble you two
piss
off
[Applause]
[Music]
what